travis barker just took a plane to cabo
with his girlfriend kourtney kardashian
marking his first time flying since he
survived a 2008 plane crash
according to tmz the lovebirds were
joined by court's mom kris jenner and
her longtime boyfriend corey gamble on
kylie jenner's private jet
that's travis dressed casually in a
white tank gray pants and black beanie
and court in a black dress with
sunglasses stepping off of the jet it
was beautiful amazing once the two
touched down court shared several snaps
from their lavish accommodations on her
insta story including a pool by the
ocean and coffee by the pool
the blink 182 drummer and his friend
adam dj am goldstein were the only two
survivors when their plane crashed on
their way home from a show in south
carolina in 2008. the crash killed
assistant chris baker security guard
charles still and the two pilots and
while they were able to escape the crash
travis was left with third-degree burns
that covered 65 percent of his body
forcing him to undergo 26 surgeries and
multiple skin grafts and about a year
after the crash adam died of an
accidental drug overdose as for travis
he's been open about the trauma he's
experienced since the plane crash in may
the musician spoke to men's health
magazine about dealing with survivor's
guilt and expressed his hope to one day
fly again quote if i saw a plane in the
sky i was determined it was going to
crash and i just didn't want to see it
now it's been so many years it's getting
easier for me there are days where i'll
wake up and never think about it barker
added that he considered the crash a
wake-up call and dedicated himself to
living a healthier lifestyle and stop
abusing drugs instead of planes travis
opted to travel by car bus and even
ships for the past 13 years he told
men's health quote if i do it and the
angels above help me in my travels and
keep me safe i would like to come back
and tell my children hey i just flew
here and then i flew home and everything
was fine
[Music]
you